ne faites pas la même erreur que netflix
et éteignez vos télés avant que ses
désastreuses aventures ne soient déjà
filmé et pas renié vous ainsi la cruelle
fantaisie et la fantasque cruauté de
serques ce marketing est complètement
has been faisons ça à ma façon
c'était la saison 1
mais ça c'est la saison 2 il y aura bien
plus de monstrueuses perfidie ou de
monstres perfide de villageois en colère
d'interventions chirurgicales inopinés
et non désiré chignole à crâne on a deux
lions mangeurs d'hommes jusqu'aux flancs
d'incendié de désespoir
coucou ma jolie
[Musique]
ça promet d'être particulièrement
épouvantable ce que j'ai hâte
[Musique]